Felicity Huffman spotted for the first
time since serving her federal prison
sentence after turning herself in
Tuesday morning the actress's photo was
snapped during a visit with husband
William H Macy and her daughter on
Saturday
Huffman can be seen in her dark green
prison uniform and a white ball cap the
56 year old started her prison sentence
earlier this week for her role in the
College Admission scandal EG learned on
Wednesday that Huffman received credit
for one day of her 14-day prison
sentence that accounted for the time she
spent in custody after her arrest in
March in addition to her prison time
Huffman was also sentenced to one year
of supervised release a 30 thousand
dollar fine in 250 hours of community
service at the time of her sentencing
Huffman released a statement that read
in part quote I'm in full acceptance of
my guilt then with deep regret and shame
over what I've done the mother of two
will remain behind bars for the duration
of her sentence at the Federal
Correctional Institute in Dublin
California
[Music]
[Applause]